[Music]
my tortillas now with more reaction to
tonight's opening monologue and the huge
news we've had all week former deputy
assistant to the president and Fox News
national security strategist Sebastian
corker and Fox News contributor Herman
Cain
you know dr. Gore could think of what we
had a week ago today we got the house
Intel the newness memo then we got the
Senate memo on Monday then we got the
unredacted version on Tuesday then we
find out that the uranium one informant
testified before three committees in
Washington the great irony here is that
we're learning that there was real
Russian problems in the election and
that's Hillary paying for Russian lies
that then gets used as a as a foundation
for a FISA warrant and that we knew 18
months in advance
of bribery extortion money laundering
kickbacks by Putin operatives in America
and we still allowed him to get 20% of
America's uranium and the mainstream
media is still stuck on Trump Russia
collusion with no evidence right Shawn
so if you want to see chapter and verse
just go to Peter Schweitzer's book or
watch the free video online on YouTube
Clinton cash documents all of this
whether it's uranium one whether it's
Haiti whether it's all the corruption
that's connected to how this this woman
and her husband became multi Multi multi
millionaires after being public servants
all their life so number one it's all
laid out there but let's look at the
recent charges and the recent things
that we've learned from Devon and from
Senator Grassley the left loves to talk
about Watergate they've you know the
movies constant references what was
Watergate allegedly the biggest
political scandal in modern times in
America which was about the cover-up
just the cover-up of one Berg bungled
burglary what do we have in this case
not one event and the cover-up we have a
systematic weaponization of federal
government under obama this isn't just
about FISA about illegally spying on
American citizens it's the IRS
it's a DOJ it is
again and again and again and look at
the trail of bodies already what is it
today we have the a person the rate of
taken right at the motor in fire or
retire or moved moved on that's that's
before we know the whole story Shaun ate
already this this is perhaps the
inflection point I am waiting for those
FBI agents those analysts those DOJ
employees who have been suffering in
silence who have been afraid but now
there's a point where they see it's
going to come out so get in front of it
now and tell us what you know well I
know many of the rank and file are and
we've gone to great pains on this
program to make sure our audience
understands this is not rank and file
FBI this is not rank and file
intelligence this is not rank and file
of the DOJ this is the upper echelon and
we have a cast of characters abusing
power Herman historically I don't see a
bigger abuse of power corruption scandal
in our history as big as this one
neither have I this is the absolute
biggest I command you and your staff for
continuing to report the facts and
connect the dots there is no question
that some laws have been broken but due
process takes time somebody should go to
jail and all roles need to the Clintons
or somebody associated with the Clintons
but it's gonna take due process and some
time before all of the dots are
connected when there was a cover-up as
dr. Walker talked about that's one thing
and when it was exposed it was out there
almost immediately this isn't a cover-up
it started out it was supposed to be
about the Trump administration or
candidate Trump and his people now we
know it wasn't it was the Democrats the
Clintons and it was all about Hillary
Clinton the most ironic
here great irony there it was you know
look at the the Graham Grassley memo
it's not only Russian they talked about
Russian government lies right fed to
steel that then is used unverified by
anybody to get a FISA warrant I mean and
the uranium one deals same thing they
knew about Clinton Putin operatives in
this country
Robert Waller was the FBI director we
had a spy with it you talk about in the
next segment Sean but but we need to
understand the enormity of this so
number one its perversion of justice to
illegally spy upon an innocent American
number one which means it can happen to
anybody watching this TV show but at the
same time when is this illegal spying
happening during a presidential election
so what we're talking about is trying to
pervert a presidential election by
giving the FBI your tainted information
to get that warrant that's that's a high
crime Sean that goes right to the the
essence of this Republic's a
constitutional order yeah you know
Herman Cain I what I'm hoping for here
is that we're able to get to the bottom
of it but if we get to the bottom of it
if if this Inspector General report
which is coming out in a couple of weeks
is all that we expect it is at all it's
going to go back to the fact that
Hillary Clinton was protected and where
someone any other American would have
gotten arrested because we have a
special category for the Clintons and
there was a massive rigging of the crime
she committed this you know people say
why you're talking about Clinton Hannity
because if we did the things she did
with the leading subpoenaed emails and
putting it into mom-and-pop shop
bathroom closet and using bleach pit and
hammers I think we would probably all be
arrested absolutely we will get to the
bottom of it because the more and more
we reveal what the facts are eventually
we will get to the bottom of it
it's not gonna go away all right guys
thank you both we appreciate it